[موسيقى]
الوصول إلى المنطقة الأكثر تضررًا من هذا
الزلزال يعني وجود قضيب مروحية على
بعد 100 ميل من أرض بورت أو برنس
، وحقيقة صدمة هايتي الأخيرة
تستقبلنا على مدرج المطار ، شاحنة انتظار
مليئة بالأشخاص المصابين خلال
عطلة نهاية الأسبوع لا تزال تنتظر  ليتم إجلاؤها
أولاً للخروج بطفل صغير يحمله
أحد أقاربه تم نقله إلى طائرة انتظار
بجانب امرأة مسنة على كرسي متحرك
غير قادرة على المشي مرفوعة من كرسيها
، لقد حملتها خطوة بخطوة حذرة
في طريقها للمساعدة التي لا تزال  يفلت
الكثير من
الأشياء خارج نطاق السيطرة في
المستشفى ، ويقول إنه لا يوجد عدد كافٍ من الأطباء ، ولا
أدوية كافية لإصابات خطيرة ، فنحن بحاجة إلى
مساعدة عاجلة قبل أن تزداد الأمور سوءًا ،
قُتل 1400 شخصًا على الأقل وأصيب
آلاف آخرون في أسوأ
زلزال يضرب هنا منذ عام 2010.
لا  بعيدًا عن المطار ، هذا ما
تبقى من فندق متعدد الطوابق
يقول المسؤولون إنه لا يزال هناك جثث في هذه
الأنقاض ، بعضها يحفر هنا في محاولة لمساعدة
الآخرين في الحفر بحثًا عن الخردة المعدنية  ومكيفات الهواء
التي لا تراها هنا هي
سلطات هايتية ليس هناك تواجد للشرطة
ولا يوجد رجال إطفاء ولا يوجد
فرق بحث وإنقاذ هنا يوجد
فقط أشخاص من المجتمع وهذه
الحفارة الوحيدة التي لا تعمل حاليًا
فهي مؤشر جدًا على ما
نحن
نرى أثناء قيادتنا للسيارة عبر هذه المنطقة بالقرب من
مركز الزلزال ، ببساطة لا تصل المساعدة
بسرعة ، جزء من السبب وراء إغلاق
الطرق مثل هذا الطريق الذي يتعذر عبوره بالنسبة لبعض
القوافل ،
فإن جهود الاستجابة تستغرق وقتًا
للوصول إلى هناك بالفعل ، أعني في رأينا
أنه يجب علينا  لقد كنت هناك بالفعل
بدأنا ولكننا لسنا راضين عن
العودة إلى المطار ، يبحث المستجيبون الأوائل
بيأس عن طريقة لإخراج هذه
الفتاة الصغيرة ، إنها رزينة ولكن
ساقها أصيبت بجروح خطيرة ومن الواضح أنها
تتألم من أن
هذه الطائرة ممتلئة بأخرى
تقلع المروحية بدونها ، وبعد أن
تجولت حول مدرج المطار ، وضعت
في شاحنة أخرى انتظارًا مؤلمًا لتلقي المساعدة
واستمر هطول الأمطار  من
نعمة الكساد الاستوائي بالطبع ،
كلما زاد هطول المطر ، زادت
مخاطر الفيضانات المفاجئة
وأشياء مثل الانهيارات الأرضية الطينية ، وهذه
هي الأشياء التي ستجعل
جهود البحث والإنقاذ هذه
أكثر صعوبة كلما زاد هطول الأمطار.
الوقت الذي يمضي في النحافة هو
فرص العثور على المزيد من الناس على قيد الحياة
في الأنقاض
مات الأنهار سي إن إن بورت أو برنس هايتي